so
do you have the x kernel uh yeah i do
have the external
okay um
okay for people joining this meeting
this is an incremental language
development
discussion uh for a future version of
language and we have a variety of topics
let's start off for the first one
coordination of arrays what else does
that even mean
yes i suggest we go to the our main
order or examples
okay that's why i don't need the x-con
or do you think i should run the whole
thing
external uh no for this you just need to
uh
there are initialization results so no
go to sorry the second main
it's a bit confusing yes that's one so
so this is a function that we have
discussed in the past
whose purpose is to take an array of
data and prepend coordinates
yes and so we need these sometimes for
numeric data
for geopositions for dates quantities
etc
and i just wanted to confirm the name
the syntax
sorry so there are examples perhaps it's
clearer
by looking at the examples yes just
evaluate and it will
it has initialization results
i'm not horrified by the name
coordinators
what do you think there is a list there
of other names we considered
the last time we discussed this
i do like a single word yeah
i mean it's really what it's doing it's
adding coordinates to things
i mean you know in even in our purest
sort of physics
point of view this is not that wrong
okay so
the default so in other words what we
will be doing here
is instead of map indexed
you could be saying uh
map something onto the coordinate eyes
of this now i suspect
there's another thing we want here which
is a function
i mean i suppose in the end it becomes
awfully like mapinsdex but it isn't
quite like map indexed
oh is that what you have oh look at that
you've already got this
what do you know right so the third
argument specifies the type of structure
you want
and this is some sort of um i want to
rule i mean
it's not fully general it's just naming
the main cases that are needed
for example the next one i think is
important if you go scroll
right so sometimes we want to flatten
those coordinates in front of the value
sometimes we don't
want to flatten and i'm not sure how to
call it i'm calling it right now
here
i mean so the first thing i mean if we
would just write that
um
uh what is the function i mean
in this one let's say that what we fed
in to a function f
was the coordinates
and the value right so this one is
correctly just called rule
this one here would be called list
right right um
let me just save this in the right place
where do we save these we really should
have a separate folder for ild here
and we do
um okay
so okay so that's the list so now
the next case is the flattened case
right
right yes so here was a reserving list
for the flattened case but perhaps we
don't need a name
for that case could be the automatic
well what is the the flattened case
is just i mean it is in fact
um you know this flattened case is
actually flattened
um at star list is it not i
see yes it is
i mean because it's the automatic case
you know
people aren't going to type that right
i prefer just having a function
especially since those two cases are
just rule and list
is the flattened case just append
um it is isn't it
you are absolutely correct
okay now what about this association
thing there that's a little different
right yes
let's combine it in
i mean if you want to go the function
way and we haven't have to have an f on
a g like
like exactly that's what i was going to
say
i mean so that becomes rule comma
association
right
um
that's a little annoying i mean we could
have a string name for that case
possibly but i don't think it's terrible
okay all right now
right so this is a scenario in which it
becomes useful so
for example to coordinate the results of
geoelevation data
and why is it that we would not have it
on a blob like a quantity or a you know
on something which is the result from
geoelevation data why not have it
understand how to have it look at the
blob and automatically coordinate eyes
based on what it can see in the blob
i didn't understand that you mean the
elevation data doing that operation
already
no i mean coordinators of geo-elevation
data
okay let me understand a couple of
things here by the way what's the
relationship of all this stuff to sparse
arrays
and by the way this form here the fact
that i can say association
um you know rule comer association
um is allows us to also say rule comma
sparse array
yeah correct yes
is that true actually or is that not
correct when we have negative numbers
there and things
well i think it depends on what those
numbers are but
i would gain on our livestream is asking
could the second argument be a function
these are functions this is exactly what
this is
right yes so so in principle i mean i'm
using integers here but
the coordinates in general will be reals
and that wouldn't make sense in
association
and sorry in inspiration okay
okay let's talk about the spec for the
coordinates
so is this a coordinate bounds
exactly yes so this this is the the
flexible thing that
you may want to specify arbitrary ranges
in a sense this is a bit like the
inverse of coordinate bounds
for those two coordinates i agree
i mean what is this is this coordinate
bounds or what is it
bounding box coordinate bounding box
which one is it it's the bounce notation
so it's it's each one is a range
so for the x coordinate and the y
coordinate exactly
yes okay and and knowing
how to divide them
is a matter of i mean if i said 2 comma
10 i'd get fractional numbers there
i wouldn't go fractional well in this
case you have two
um
i didn't understand that
i'm i'm saying i'm saying if if this is
okay if i say one two three you'll get
it stephen
right yeah okay but the basic point is
this is the range of values and so what
is going to happen is
this is using essentially subdivide if
i'm remembering correctly
to determine what the actual coordinate
values are
correct yes
um okay so in the case
here where
i mean this is very very very very very
messy
so this is just the handling of i want
my values centered at a at the cell
so that's why the dx is just a little
bit of offset
okay so for example these this value
this array of of elevation data for the
whole world of 256
512 points ourselves are like um
yeah i get it so but the thing i'm i'm
concerned about here is that you know
okay i got multiple points here
first point is you know in a time series
for example
starting and ending time so this would
be uh
you know you can extract from a time
series it's start and its end or
something
um
okay so what are the cases right so
this is these are the data values by the
way they're not
there's no mechanism here to make those
logarithmic values for example
right you'd have to go in subsequently
after you've coordinated
euclideanly or whatever and go and make
a
scaling function right it's
it's possible that coordinators should
support a scaling function
just like graphics does
somewhat like the way that um um
uh
um
yeah let's see so
right that would be a nice thing to have
now what what other things are there
that ticks allow in terms of picking
their values
because this is essentially a ticks-like
specification if i'm not mistaken
you're right that's a good point
um so perhaps this is
we could accept a list of axis objects
and these would immediately put
the things yeah politics or something
like that
yeah it's a good idea um
i'm a little confused by exactly what
that would do but something like this is
a good idea
okay
so nick is commenting coordinate here is
like an adjustable version of position
yeah it's like map indexed except that
you are
giving it
i mean an interesting question is how
does coordinators interact with map
indexed
well if you don't specify the second
argument it is effectively map indexed
but if you want to specify the ranges
then this is more flexible than mapping
next for sure
but i'm saying if you wanted map indexed
you know if you want a map index to
operate with ranges so to speak
what would you do oh the function
the function in the first argument
taking the
the position would have to do some sort
of rescale yeah exactly but i mean so
in other words if map index finds that
um finds that at that level
there are 18 elements that it is about
to map
across it could in principle there could
be a wrapper
much like the um uh well how could it
work
uh how could it work no it couldn't work
without map index having a third element
that's fed to the
uh it's up you know the function that it
is applying
telling it what the overall range is for
that level
right but one wonders i mean maybe you
could have a map coordinatized or
something
that would that would do this yeah
that would be just like map index if it
had the extra argument for
for the bounds which i think would
actually be easier to understand than
this
then you would require a mapping
function
yeah you'd have to put in a function
well i mean so so i i think this is a
useful function by the way i mean but
map coordination is not totally
coordinating
so that would be a function f and an
expert there
and if you map at level two for example
it's going to know so let's say you map
at level two
and there are you know you've got a list
abc and you've got another list
a b x y z
um then it's going to know that one of
those
um is uh
um you get what i'm saying one of those
is less
but where do we say that we are mapping
over
angular degrees yeah you need i think
you need a bounds argument in there
right
i see but the default case
um okay so the default case of this
is just the equivalent to map indexed
with the list
yes so if i just said
you would have to use reverse applied
what do i have to use um wrap list in
reverse applied
because you see it we want the
coordinate before the value
okay
okay although in this case you are
you're doing the flattening here but if
i were to do a coordinator's
list okay i want to address a different
issue which is
what does geo elevation data so let's
say geo elevation data
of um i don't know
um idaho okay
so this is presumably going to return to
me what is this going to return
so this is first downloading a polygon
and then it's finding a good resolution
for that polygon and returning an array
but it's just the array of values now
this is a problem this doesn't have
coordinates
right so the question is could this have
metadata this quantity array have
metadata
so that i could just do the one argument
coordinate
eyes and that would add
the appropriate metadata you know that
the appropriate coordinates
uh i see what you mean so for the very
particular case of geo elevation data
we found another way which is there is a
third argument specifying the type of
output you want and the second argument
is the type of elevation so if you say
here
comma automatic comma your position it
returns something that contains
coordinates
right so now that your position contains
triples
latitude longitude elevation i say
because zero position can have a z
height exactly but this is very special
of the elevation data if we had some
other i don't know
magnetic something and we needed some
other coordinates which are not not
let alone we couldn't do it
or if we have the already the array if
the array is what we start with
yeah we don't have that information so i
think we need to understand these flows
because for example if i say something
like
um uh population of spain
okay i get this i accept it
and then i say dated here
all
so now i'll get a time series
um well that time series is all
hunky-dory i mean that's not
that's already got essentially
coordination in it
the issue is what if i had done um
values of normal of that
what the heck what happened here i i
think i think
do you want values of the time series or
normal
oh i see values of the time series yeah
okay values are percent 73.
okay fine um
right so normal of the time serious
would be the coordinating form
that's correct but then the values
or a coordinate is a coordinated form
because actually normal i'm going to
check one thing here which i hope is
correct
that um oh come on
this is another bug to report these
should be granularized by year
uh yes yes time serious doesn't
understand generality yet
i hope you're in the time series meeting
tomorrow
i don't think i am well you need to
insert yourself there can we make sure
you're there
because that's that that's an important
point about granularity for time series
um okay well anyway so that that's
but the point there okay so you're
saying in this case
that normal is precisely a coordinating
form
it's precisely coordinate you know the
flattened coordinate ized form
right so ideally here we would have
coordinates of the list of populations
coma
a pair of dates it would return exactly
this
right right
except okay yeah that that would be
hunky-dory if
wow it states in the future um
it will be hunky-dory if these were
equally spaced
which they're not in fact so so it's
going to give silliness but that's
there's nothing we can do about that
if you've lost the data you've lost the
data
um
okay so the the question is here
i this is this a special case this thing
where you're going i mean
this is just generating the coordinate
bounds and this is kind of a yucky way
of coordinate generating the coordinate
bounds
um
but i mean
okay let me ask this question anything
that can occur in range
can presumably occur no anything that
can occur in subdivide
can occur in that so if i say subdivide
what is it called subdivide um
of let's say year 1600
why doesn't that give a yellow box
that's another bug please
year 1650 okay
and then i'm subdividing by one year
right
i think no here that would be range you
would have to say the number of
of uh segments you want
not good yes i think we haven't prepared
for this case
updates okay well so let's understand
the range case
yeah so here we would say quantity one
one year or five yes
hunky dory okay so this case was wrong
but this is fine
so this case has to be got right and
then coordinators would work with
with dates
yes okay let me ask you another question
in okay so i think that's one case that
should work the other case that should
work
is coordinate eyes
of a list well of a array
comma geo position 1
geo position 2. right so in other words
those geo positions are implicitly
specifying
transposed two level represent you know
x y coordinate ranges
do you get what i'm saying yes we we
could i mean
we enter a bit the discussion of
bounds there versus bondage box i know i
know that
i know that but in this case there's
nothing else this could mean
yes i guess so but it will be very
special of your positions
correct an exception yes well that's
because
you know the the um the question is how
special is space relative to all
possible
you know things that can be represented
with with three coordinates
or something i think we think we'll
we'll admit that space is somewhat
special relative to
i mean i think it's okay i mean in in
the astro case i can imagine some
three-dimensional
thing here
okay but the array
so yeah okay are there any other special
cases we need to consider here
no i think quantities dates and your
positions are
apart from numbers of course are the
main things to support
okay nick is suggesting map coordinators
can accept a function that accepts a
coordinate in its second slot
right exactly that that it would accept
not
the index position
but the coordinate position correct
right guys but you know the map indexed
is always using the raw part number
position
but map coordinatized would accept the
coordinate position
rather than the
i mean by the way
i could imagine map coordinators being
useful function for mapping over things
like time series
that's a separate discussion where it
could automatically pick up the
coordinates
from the actual structure like the time
series
i i don't yet understand the need of the
mapping function
because i mean here we would have values
and coordinates
i would expect more like having a
function that maps directly on
coordinates and computes
the field at that point but the array is
already the field
fair point right look
let's let's go further with coordinators
and let's see if we can
nail everything with that okay let me
just understand the map coordinators
again yeah
okay so you're saying
the issue is this let's take this case
here
well i mean your point is you need to
specify more for this anyway
yes the boundaries are needed that's the
fundamental
so this function is a bit like a causing
of rescale
i guess
um
yeah that's right it's it's like putting
a rescale into the
uh uh part number specification
but my point that the the unique thing
here
which perhaps is is not relevant is that
in this case where you go at level two
okay even if i didn't
no i see if i if i gave bounds
here and i said this is always going
from zero to one
but there are three elements here and
there are five elements here
right then this would end up with
different coordinates this will be the
equivalent
of so in the map index case what this
would be
is map indexed
i mean it's a little bit tricky right
because i've got to be able to say
in here i've got to be able to say
basically it's a map indexed of a map
indexed
of list comma or
f but it doesn't really matter f comma
and then here it's
well it's this is this is a mess right
because i've got to have a function
there
function of x i'll be really happy when
code assistance gives on the possibility
of adding this without
having to think about adding it um
you got where i'm going here we're going
to have a you gotta have something which
is
hash comma
2 over length of x
map indexed over x
and then that thing there okay like that
see what i'm saying somehow these are
independent calls
so i think what you are doing is having
a separate
coordination for each vector that's
right
well and so you say why not just map the
coordinators over it
uh yes it's one with the with the bounce
needed
so the the view i was suggesting
requires
something rectangular in the first
argument
yes and that's why why
it gets the values the values of the
coordinates
the output can be rugged which is the
discussion of the next section
okay all right okay okay fine
all right this looks good okay so then
we'll continue with coordinating
and i will implement this various cases
you
suggested here
gregory is commenting subdivision method
is a substitution subsequent to dividing
i think that's a different issue with
adaptive subdivision and so on which is
not what we're dealing with here
all right so let's okay so this is
something here you say i need to use the
external is that right yes
okay so this is a more general
discussion that we started
i mean a few months ago and rob has
extended it and it's now more powerful
so the general idea is
those cases in which we have an array
which is not fully rectangular
but almost it has some sort of
ruggedness somewhere but it's still
pretty regular
so how can we find it and how can we
describe that regularity and how can we
perhaps even impose it back in some data
okay so what you what are you saying so
you're saying
i'm i'm a little bit confused here yeah
so
imagine all these cases so these are
just examples in which they are they are
not
rectangular they are rugged but still
there is a
rather strong structure right we feel
it's it's pretty regular
so the dimensions is not going to be
able to capture that
so let me just understand in what sense
okay so
if we imagine i mean okay so let me make
a naive
thing here okay so we do this i've got
an idea here
um we do this and we say
um let's see i want position
in that of underscore symbol
i see
all right okay i i understand i think i
mean i'm i'm trying to think about this
in term
go ahead you have a some kind of
calculus
for thinking about this case right so
these are examples of how
ruggedness appears frequently in our
computations
and sometimes it is it is rugged
but not much so for example the first
two cases which is which are the cases
we were discussing before
are very regular because all elements of
the lists have this structure
of percoma value i understand
and and that regularity
in a sense what's happening is there is
a pattern
for the part numbers right
that appear so what we want is
some sort of generalization of
dimensions and and the calculus of
dimensions that is able to
represent that structure right but the
thing that i just said
is i think the right comment which is
there is a
pattern a simple pattern in our sense of
a pattern
for the part numbers that appear is that
a true statement or not
rob um
you might be able to express it as a
pattern yeah
okay all right okay
let's keep going then yes so these are
just smaller examples so it appears in
interpolation for example interpolation
input
uh or for example in polygons we have
these arrays
in which we have lists of values so here
the regularity
is at the deeper level so it's just
dragged arrays of vectors all right
let's see the
well okay what is almost right okay okay
so this is a case in which it's almost
regular but the very last one
is not right so it's like a partition
with an opportunity
exactly so so how can we describe cases
like this because dimensions is going to
give up immediately
it will just say i have four elements
yeah
okay so this is what we yeah we suggest
so yes you can evaluate this if this is
the x column
it is the hex kernel
yeah so that's an ordinary case yeah
let me try doing something where i start
smooshing this
this array
so let's see so we will discuss the the
syntax but this means
i have two vectors of length two and i
have one
vector of length one this is right from
right to left so the dimensions is on
the left hand side of the rules
then the multiplicity on the right hand
side of the root
i mean in the pattern language it would
be it would be repeated
what would this be in the pattern
language so this is saying
this here what does this really mean
ragged dimensions what this really means
it's an outer product
of okay in terms of the part
specifications the part specs here
above are outer products basically
um of of range
blah blah blah right
so so in particular what this is
is isn't there another form of outer
list what is outer list anyway
isn't there something else that means
outer list
some kind of tuples thing okay so that
with certain flattening right is
the part is the collection of part
specifications
correct yes okay
so in general what we're trying to do
with with dimensions or something
generalizing dimensions is it is a
summary
of a collection of part specifications
so for example
in
i'm not very clear actually what let's
do a a catinate of this
okay so now what is the
pattern that would represent this it's a
little bit messy isn't it i mean it's
basically something like
x blank y blank um slash semi
one less than or equal to x less than or
equal to
uh three yep
and one less than
actually whatever it is less than or
equal to x
less than or equal to three
oops uh
okay one less than equal y
less than equal to okay
correct yep that's correct yep
okay all right so now here
we've got a slightly more complicated
pattern specification where
we could say this together with
well it's not quite right i mean it's
okay
well within alternatives basically to
specify that case
so the the idea of rocket is
simultaneously doing two things
one is expressing raggedness and the
other one is repetition
so we are interested in both the
dimensions the fact that we have objects
of
of length two and one rather than all of
them being
length two and also the number of times
each one is repeated so that's where
that's a new idea that becomes powerful
for example with uh
with former with with the examples we
have further now
okay all right okay look at this case
for example in which we have the
these matrix produced by coordinators
so there we still have two levels which
are fully irregular
the three and the two but then inside
we what we see is that we have pairs
with one vector of length two and one
scalar
this guy's here right so
okay so you're saying this means
this level is a pure
see i'm a little bit confused by this
because i think okay
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to summarize as you go through
each level so think about this as a tree
right what you're saying so that's a
different kind of representation so if i
take this
and i say expression tree of that
by the way we have to get a way to do
this so that doesn't have labels in it
do you know how to do that is there a
way to do that
we discussed adding another structure
like an optional second argument to
expression tree just for the case of
nested lists
yeah okay but i i just want to easily be
able to say vertex labels our own none
and just get rid of that stuff and just
have the structure of the tree
we will add um options soon at the
moment we have to map
not
um
so in a sense what that that that those
previous dimensions mean is that that
structure is repeated
you know so so along that last row you
have exactly the same structure repeated
over and over again
at level three
right so but this is saying as i go from
the top of the tree
right then the first thing i'm saying is
that this is a full level
with three three things on it and then
i'm going to a full level with two
things on it
and then here so in a sense this is
something we could also imagine
describing trees with right at this
level
there are some elements
you're saying that everything
is i mean if if over here something
different happened
but this is saying every sub-tree is
identical
here right right yes so so this is
essentially a
you know what you're saying is
previously it was a what are those
things called a complete tree what are
those called
a carry i mean a complete what the heck
is it called
when you have a tree which has identical
branching at every level i'm not sure
but a uniform tree of some kind balanced
oh yeah that's what it is it's balanced
right
so um
then this is saying there are identical
subtrees
i'm now going to describe this so the
naive thing that i would do
is to go up from the bottom of the thing
saying is everything an identical
subtree
if it is i just need to count how many
elements there are at that level
right
if it is but here there are things which
are non-identical subtrees
make sense yep
um
okay by the way i'm noticing on a live
stream
ali has been asking about um uh
bug tribunal bug
sessions i've been wondering about that
too so i've been asking about this
repeatedly myself so at least
yeah we should we should get this done i
i this is that's something for
addison to go chase with unowed and
people i don't know why that hasn't
happened
so i'm i'm keen to have that happen as
well um
and in particular because it is a time
of year when we are about to
i'm about to dive into my few weeks of
extreme professoring with our summer
school and summer camp and this year
also a middle school summer camp
um the uh uh that that
that thing should get done before before
i
go and play professor for a few weeks
extreme professor i would say it's much
more extreme when it's a question of uh
figuring out how many will it be this
year
oh my gosh it's like 120 projects it's
like having
it's like you're fed 120 graduate
students in
in um in one week just
yeah anyway um okay
irrelevant uh okay but so i think this
is a good way to think about it in terms
of subtrees
if i'm not mistaken and nick is pointing
out that
that it matters that this is the big sub
tree comes first and the little sub
tree comes next
okay so let me just understand what is
list reshape
right so this is the function that would
take data and would
reshape the data into the given shape
okay so tell me what that means as a
tree function
so did yeah this is a good idea
this is definitely a good idea
right and rob has some examples so so
sort of what it means from a tree point
of view is you
you you consider the tree structure and
you do a
depth first depth first reversal of that
tree structure
and every time you hit a node a bottom
node you would
grab an element from that from that
flattened list
and and you put that into the into the
the result
i'm trying to understand that i mean the
thing we're trying to describe here
okay here's a way to think about it okay
in in list reshape
basically what you're saying is you do a
depth first traversal you got one one
a one two b two one c et cetera et
cetera et cetera
and then this is the cookie cutter that
you're trying to take
that list and reconstitute it
as this tree that is your reading from
that list
doing i see i understand what you said
now so what you're doing is you're
taking a depth first traversal
of this structure and at every step
you are progressively inserting
at every place where you reach a leaf
node you're inserting the next element
from that
so how does this relate to tree fold and
things like this
let's remind ourselves what does tree
fold do
yes i think this is something that could
be mapped on a tree and sequentially
insert
i i right now don't know how to create
this pool of
data that would be inserted but no but i
mean isn't tree fold
okay let's remind ourselves what is tree
fold doing
tree fold is doing something
i see tree fold is returning a list
from the fold operation on the tree
yes right what the heck
what on earth just happened there
i have no idea and when i hit the syntax
well this is
this is the external right okay all
right
okay um
okay so so here this is walking the tree
using that as the thing to be folded in
and producing a list but we want the
inverse operation
that is we want to take
what do you mean producing a list
of producing an f sorry producing a
nested f object
right three-fold list would presumably
produce a list
right is there a treefold list i mean
it's
it isn't quite like nested f's
because the second arguments don't have
head f
okay let's not deal with this right now
although i would like to put
a little pin in the tree fold list
question
okay so so up here what we're saying is
we've got the plain list
and now the reconstitution
so the the sort of the raggedness
template
you know rob wants to treat it as just
the plain list of
leaves but he wants but but
we're saying we're interpreting that
plain list of leaves
as this thing which has non-trivial
structure in the tree
non-trivial repeating structure in the
tree exactly
and that's basically the idea behind
that packed packed list idea
yeah i get it i get it i get it so i
mean in other words what you're doing is
you're saying
um for purposes of how the data
structure is laid out in memory or
who knows what it is it's just the list
of leaves
but we have an interpretation of that
list of leaves just like just like an
old fortran array or something maybe
it's you know the old
how did is that right how fortran did it
where you have um
uh you know what i'm talking about where
you where you're laying out the whole
two-dimensional array
and then you have to just index into you
know if it's a five by ten array
for example you know what i'm talking
about rather than one
wise i think strangely
just different order but the same is
same idea of far away
our pact arrays do the same internally
okay fine all right okay fine so so that
so that's what we're talking about we're
talking about
now we have a function don't we that is
is it
takeless or is it something different
what is the function that we have that
goes
from a plain unraveled list
yeah the tech list can partition with
different layouts
but this is a lot more powerful because
in a very compact notation
we can implement a complicated structure
like the one you have there
no i understand but in some sense it's a
bit like to what extent is it like take
list in other words
what is the operation that we need to do
let's say we've got the one one a one
two b
et cetera et cetera et cetera okay so
this is another way to look at it
instead of my pattern thing which i'm
not so keen on anymore
um we're asking what is the operation
that you need to do
to the flattened list to de-flatten it
right so so one thing we would do is to
say partition the list right
partition that whatever it is that thing
there
that we might say you know the flatten
of that
um uh
partition that into threes let's say
okay great now but what we want to do is
we want to do
a super partition in which it ends up as
one one a
not the flat thing here is that correct
with take a list you can change the
partition to take list and the three to
at least i don't know one two three four
what do i do here just add a list like
range
four or range five or something
but that's not the can i do the exact
thing what we're doing here can i can i
get this to work
that's the power of this this is
something new that at the moment we
cannot do with anything now
that's i mean that's that's what this
reshape is is
does but what what
what's the relationship to array reshape
it's it's it's list reshape is a ray
reshape when the dimensions are regular
i see so so in other words that we could
feed into a ray reshape
array reshape is again assuming regular
dimensions so to speak
as opposed to us allowing ragged
dimensions yeah and one of the points
jose makes is if we
if we sort of you know start to consider
these as sort of dimension type
things then a ray reshape could just
take that sort of specification
and it would work right
there are examples in the next section
okay ethan is making an interesting
comment here neither easy way to
recursively
add children if you want to pass some
large xml org chart for a company
into a tree i see what you're saying is
but i'm not sure that that's really an
issue because i think we're going to
have xml to
tree translation so it isn't the case
that
you need a gluing operation you know
it's not like you're going to do that
that would be like saying
you know in a in a primitive low-level
programming language the way that people
would you know
add elements to a list is they'd go
through you know to translate from one
list to another they do for i equals
zero i less than whatever i plus plus
a you know a pen blah blah blah and i
think we're saying that for trees
we should have much more one gulp
operations to go from xml trees to our
internal
symbolic trees um
yeah ethan is saying we need some real
world data monitoring examples
to show the utility of the new tree
functionality yes i mean 12
3 is just the beginning of the tree
functionality coming
uh hopefully in the next version will be
all the stuff for xml html
etc and other many other kinds of
large-scale trees
um that just wasn't you know that that's
that's the nature of these incremental
releases that was not ready yet
um okay but let's come back to this so
what you're saying is
you know again i i want to repeat again
what it is that you're saying what
you're saying is because i could imagine
actually using a tree as a template
right like rather than giving the whole
ragged ragged ragged thing
what if i just said my template
is blank blank
comma blank but you see
it's like with i mentioned with
dimensions we can have a million and we
wouldn't have to
have a model of a million size we just
have the number a million
no i know i get it i get it i get it but
what i'm saying is
this is saying how to turn the lowest
level dimension
this is saying what that dimension is i
would argue that an
ordinary dimension is a blank dimension
right a single blank dimension whereas
what this is saying is
every element at this level every
element at level three
is in fact not a
you know just a pure blank underneath it
it is a this structure underneath it
i see that making any sense yes i think
it does yeah
we were we wanted to gain also the
repetition idea so if instead of two
blanks you had a million blanks
we want to have blank arrow okay i get
it i get it i get it so what you're
saying is
okay what you're saying is that you want
to represent this
just as essentially two comma
well okay that's a little tricky isn't
it because i mean this is
this is a length two object and this
next thing
is what is that object is it a length
zero object
yes probably a scalar
okay but but if i have i can have an
arbitrarily complicated subtree here
and you're saying at every level
instead of saying it's a it's an it's a
okay so the way i would think about this
as i go down this tree
i'm simply asking i've got a level
everything's the same
okay i've got a level this is now things
are different so this is a two
and a zero and if i went down if i
can somebody make me another tree that
has some
more levels of of weird stuff in it like
let's say those threes
let's imagine that that element there
um let's imagine these elements here
these second elements
here um
have another tree hanging off them could
we easily make that
just change those two ones to some list
one comma zero some player
so it's devices just the two ones
expression right so here i want to just
change
this to an x y for example
right but now i've got to do because
i've got to make it the same
for every subtree
okay all right so this is now the next
case
right an inverse way of doing it stephen
which is interesting is you can take
take a dimension structure you want and
use this
reshape with the empty list it pads to
zero
and you can actually get the figure and
see what the structure actually is
what you you're saying that if i take
this okay but don't worry i just want
you go ahead if you want to understand
what a you know what structure like one
of these dimension structures is you
just do list
reshape and you could take you could
take that rag of dimensions for example
that you have above do list reshape of
empty list comma that
there are examples further though oh
maybe that's
right and then that create and then you
can look at the tree for the expression
tree of that
now you could also add another you could
copy that ragged at the end
and it would have two levels of
raggedness
i need that before that thing there yeah
oh dear oh sorry stephen
oh well i was gonna i think if you put a
1 there a 2 there or something or at
least repeat that too so that's
that's a bug in the implementation
obviously but
i don't know so something something's
very sorry about that
okay all right but okay let me look at
these examples here
yeah i get it i get it i mean this is
sort of the um
i get the notion that this is a
it's like an old fortran array it's just
it's it's got
a way of describing what that position
should mean
in the original in the original setup
right it's a bit more general than the
old 410 array but yes
that's i'm making um
and i think stephen this could you know
and some of the types of examples you've
had for the compiler where you have
these sort of
you know weird structured lists this
this could actually be a very powerful
very powerful thing to deal with those
no it's a good idea i mean basically it
becomes a type
in the compiler that we then can handle
precisely because the argument would be
a decent fraction of very big
structures have lots of things that
repeat in them
although it's not always the case
because i would claim there's a
different case
which is you know something where
there's a million elements and each
element is either two or three
a sub list of either two or three
elements and so in other words
that's like a struct there's a finite
collection of possibilities
instead of it being the case that
everything is
level based so to speak that there's a
finite collection of possibilities
within that large
uh list right and that would be a
different
so so this this this does well for
sequences which are the same so if you
have a bunch of threes
and then a bunch of twos this works
great this this particular
thing but but if you if you have a
finite collection
this is not the ideal data so a typical
case of finite collection is missing
data
right where things are usually sublist
except they might be missing data
yeah okay but this case is already
interesting so
we you know the real point for me is
understanding this
this ragged construct which i'm not
initially very
taken with um
at least not understanding what go ahead
given that it has rules
we could remove the rugged hair and just
have a list
it would look nicer i think it would
actually look much nicer too
right i mean you know unfortunately
dimensions
well we couldn't use this in dimensions
it would have to be in new dimensions
generalization of dimensions right right
um which is fine
i mean that's okay yeah my my original
name was something like
generalized dimensions and then you know
hoseana came
um okay by the way ethan is commenting
that depth first scan should work on
tree
that's i think something for ian
i don't know if ian has a comment on
that
and i think we discussed with charles
the idea that trees would be
interpreted by the graph functions via
trigraph it may not be implemented yet
okay but that's an obvious thing to do
um okay but i want to come back to this
okay so you're proposing
that in this case
i'm still very confused by notation
i'm very confused by this notation i
just don't understand this at all
i i why are you not just giving a thing
why is this why is there an arrow one
here i don't understand that at all this
thing just looks like it's a sub list
a a dimension in which
the subtree in which basically what's
happening is
that this object itself is just a
miniature version
it's the um i'm sure it has a name in
category theory
what we're doing here um we want to take
some sort of outer
so if we want to take miniatures the
miniature
approach which is what rob started doing
ends up with models that are very big so
i think i have an example further down
which is rather complicated and and it's
well i get it i mean what you want to do
is be able to say
i i think we're being confused here okay
so i claim that you just go down level
by level
and at each level let's take the example
of this guy here
okay yep okay so in in my claim this
would look like
okay first level is three okay next
level is
is is two right
next level is a list because it isn't
one
thing and
the first argument of that list
is i claim the list
zero i'm not sure why we need these
zeros that's a little weird
let's actually write none there because
i think that's more tree-like
comma none i claim that's the
that's the pattern that's the that's the
structuring template
for um
that's the structuring template and i'm
i'm modeling this over
over the way that tree does things
although it might not be i might not
have that right
exactly
did you get what i'm saying yes yes yeah
so i think that too should be in a list
but
but besides that yeah
why should that to be in the list
because it's a it's a list with
dimensions two
dimensions the dimensions of that xy
right no i don't think so i don't that
should anymore be in the list than these
things should be in lists
the only reason there's a list here is
because i'm breaking a level
to not just be a pure number
but it's a complete level so when we
have a
sequence of objects of different
dimensions we have to consider the full
dimensions of those objects it could be
a matter yeah
so suppose you had a million elements
that level you'd have to list
all of those out with your notation even
though
which what do you mean a million
elements of that level well do do
partition uh partition of range of 101
comma two and then whatever the argument
is to
to pad with the empty list i think maybe
that's the empty padding
let me see oh fine up to two thank you
that's
see i've forgotten that okay now now do
the ragged dimensions of that
see this keeps it super compact whereas
i
understand i don't understand i don't
understand but i'm what i'm suggesting
is
i'm totally confused by your complaint
here okay what i'm suggesting is
in this case i think i'm suggesting this
is a list
oh i see what you're saying
do i see what you're saying it's a it's
it's like i mean in the pattern language
this is repeated
yeah we're using rule the represent
repeated
or maybe we should just use repeated
if there's an interpretation in the
pattern language of this
construct
yeah perhaps repeat it of list 2 comma
50
good work
so then this would look like repeated 2
comma 50 comma 1.
correct will be the form of that
that level
so normally you'd be able to just say
in a case like this you could just use
three two blah blah
but in this case this is the shorthand
notation
that avoids you having to write a huge
number of repeats of that
subtree right exactly and
and you know it's
i mean it's nice having a consistent
structure so so that's why we
did the rule goes to one to to just have
consistent structure there but it's not
i'm not sure that's the
nicest thing because i think if if the
more common case
is that it will be that the sub trees
will be quite small at the bottom
and all the bigness will be at the
higher levels you'll never see that
yeah but i would argue that
that the the two i mean what does that
mean it's gonna be a
thing of length two so so what do you
what do you use to represent just a
scalar
i mean not a thing without any length
well i don't know that's what i was
using none for above
again i i'm trying to ask him apparently
down here i'm trying to ask
in the analogy with trees right
um well actually in the end the pattern
language would be
it would be exceptive list right
yes it would be but i'm asking in the
trees space
case i think we have a way of
representing there is a leaf here
i guess ian isn't here he's listed as
being here i'm here
okay are you able to respond to what i
was just saying
i don't see the connection between uh
tree leaf and dimensions okay i don't
think you're paying enough attention
i i think the problem here is that in
trees we don't have a way of expressing
repetition
no that's not the point i'm making the
point i'm making is that what we're
trying to deal with is something which
has is a pure
leaf a leaf node of a tree what's the
way of representing
a a tree which is just a leaf node what
it is is it has
no sub trees and this is the way around
we're finally doing is that right
sub trees are first it's it's paleo
list yep yep okay fine so that's saying
there is no this is a pure leaf that's
what i'm that's what i'm mimicking here
there's a pure leaf as opposed to it has
sub elements
yeah yes but the dimensions language
itself if you do dimensions of
three gives you empty list and i think
for self-consistency we have to support
that i'm sorry dimensions of what
as the number three yes okay well fair
enough
all right listen i have to go i'm
supposed to do actually another live
stream
um and i need something to eat before i
do that
um this is a very interesting thing
i i feel like you haven't sold me on the
precise notation that you have
perhaps it would help maybe putting an
association there would be a better
thing
i don't know exactly
something is very hard to read about
these notes about this notation
i like the idea of repeated of of having
players
repeated dimensional command number and
perhaps
we just have a list not no rugged object
to look suddenly
yeah yeah i think the repeated is is
is good because that makes it much
clearer what it is
right well let's try that there may be
some other issues with it
um all right
i should run off here um
very interesting it's a good thing i i'm
very excited about the idea of being
able to use this in the compiler and so
on
okay well you know i'll i'll
develop it a bit further and and
you know i'll i'll certainly try a
compiler compiler thing
as i get further along right okay
sounds good all right thanks a lot
everybody thanks for the comments on the
live stream
and uh ali the the bug
event uh we need to do it thank you for
pushing it
it will get pushed um
okay talk